تركي ايرس دو وودي كانومي تريبل
وم
[موسيقى]
دايس واحد الى الايام عندما كانت التكلفه
هي المساله الوحيده المهمه
لمصادر الانتاج والسلاسل والاسلوب عمل
سلاسل توريد
اوضحت لنا بامنا امنا التموين
يتطلبون
اذكياء للمحافظه
ادراك
كله سيكون فيها اكثر فقرا واقل وامنا
خوفيه
استيقظوا افعلوا الصواب
[تصفيق]
اكبر اقتصاد في العالم وكذلك
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده
الى
مساعدتي الى المكسيك وتحالفكم هل ترون
مرحله
صندوق النقد الدولي كي يحصل هنالك نموت
سنوات القادمه
الصيني الفرص مثلا وسط امريكا ولكن لا
يعتقد بانها
ستكون بدرجه القوه المتوقعه
بس سيكون الكتاب اقتصاد امام فاتحا
للتجاره الحره
لتعرف على القيمه الكبير التي وفرتها
العولمه للعالم الكثيره من الشعوبنا
هذه مساله حساسه وليس واضحا اذا ما كان
مسيوخ المنقسم سيكون رايه فيما يخص سياسات
التجاره ولكن هنا ثم يخص قانون
واحد من اكبر التشريعات التي مررها
بالمناسباتيه وفي ابحاثنا العلميه وكذلك
استقلال الطاقه
اه استمع الى كلمات
ندركوا مع اننا
نطبقوا هذه الاستثمارات الكبيره فيجب ان
نفعل ذلك بيعين على شركائنا وحلفائنا
ونفعل ذلك ليس فقط لمصلحتنا بالمصلحه
العالم
يفتقدناه في قانون تغطيه قانون
التكنولوجيا الطاقه النظيفه التي يمكن ان
تنفع على علامه كلها من اداره المئتين
وحبس المائتين وحبسه الكربون والمفعله
الصغيره فاذا اخذنا قريه رساله من
القانوني
للتعدد او نتخلى عن اسواق العالميه التي
ساعدت في تحقيق الكثير من التقدم عبر
العاقل الماضي فلا اعتقد من هذه قراءه
صحيحه اعتقد الطاقه والاستقلال وليس
محاليل او اعزنا عن الاخرين اعتقد بان
تطبيق هذا القانون همم سوف يثبت انه
ايجابي للعالم اكثر البعض
الامير فيصل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي واحده من
اكبر منتجيه الطاقه في العالم وفي هذا
الحوار
تكلفه المعيشه بالتاكيد اسعار النفط
مهمه للغايه
على ذلك
كذلك
المنطقه التي تقع فيها العربيه السعوديه
هناك كانت معقده فا ربما لك ان همم تحدثنا
عن هذه المسالتين في ما يخص الطاقه امن
الطاقه
الاستقرار هو العامل الاساسي لان الطاقه
المستهلكين والمنتجين بعض مصادر الطاقه
الاخرى واجهتها تحديات كبيره جدا في هذا
الخصوص وارتفاعات كبيره ونحن ملتزمون بذلك
والملتزمون ايضا بمستقبل الطاقه النظيف
ولكن سبيل الوحيد لاتحول الى مستقبل طاقه
نظيف بشكل لا يؤثر على المسائل التي سمعنا
عنها
اول يوم كانت الوصول اليها ودوا العالم
النابي لكي يستمر مساره تجاه الازدهار هي
لتكهنئه الاستقرائي للتمويل مصادر الطاقه
التقليديه بينما يستثمر الخطوط الطاقه
المتجدده المملكه مثلا تستثمر 200 مليار
دولار في الطاقه النظيفه في المملكه
وخارجها والشركات هنا الشرطه في 21 دوله
حول العالم
الامريكي كلهم يكفي من الطاقه لاستبدال
للوقود الطاقه التقليديه ولكن مع الوقت
يجب انه حافظت على الطاقه النظيفه
واسعارها تضمن هذا الاستقرار وتمكنا من
تحقيق ذلك هذا هو احساسنا بالتاكيد ونستمر
معالجه هذه المساله بشكل مسؤول
الدول الجوار نحن نركز على المسائل
الايجابيه وليس على السلبيه لان منطقتنا
ايضا اظهرت بوادرا انه هو حتى في الظروف
القاسيه امكانيه تحقيق النجاح اقتصاد
المملكه حسب المثال سيكون اسرع نموها في
العالم هذا العام عبر برامج اصلاح حاطه
نوع جدا 20 30 كما كنا من تحويل الى
اقتصاد بشكل كبير بعيدا عن الاعتماد على
هذا الكربون والنفط كمصدر نفط للحكومه
الاجمالي هذه العمليه مستمره ونحن نقوم
بتفعيل كافه انواع اي مجالات الاقتصاد
الابطال انخفض بشكل كبير ومشاركه القوى
العامله كبيره خاصه النساء فكل هذه بوادر
حتى فيها المنطقه الصعبه العالم بامكانه
تحقيق النجاح وعندما نتحدث عن ايران
تواصلنا معهم ونحاول ايجاد السبيل للحوار
مع جيراننا لاننا نؤمن بشده بان الحوار هو
السبيل الامثل لحل الخلافه
ونشعر بقوه
اخرنا في المنطقه خاصه دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي لمعالجه التحديات اقتصاداتهم
والاستثمار في جولهم والتركيز على التنميه
وليس على المساله السياسيه هذه علامه قويه
لايران واخرين في المنطقه هنالك مسار
بعيدا عن الجدالاتين ونزاعات القديمه
اتجاهها للزهاره المشتركه كلما تمكنا من
بناء احساس بالتعاون في المنطقه كلها
عملنا معا كلما حققنا الازدهار ليس فقط
للشاعر بينام بللي منطقتنا وخارجها
شكرا العلاقه مع جاركم وانا افكره هنا بعد
الصيف كانت هناك بعض التكافاه هناك
بعض التحديات في العلاقه مع الولايات
المتحده
هل هذا صحيح وهمم
اه تداعي بالنسبه
لمملكه العربيه السعوديه وامريكا
بعلاقتكم قريبه جدا بالتاكيد العلاقات اقل
وتحديه مع هذا الجار واكثر اقل بكثير من
الجار الاخر لتحدثنا عنه
ونستمر بالعمل
دائما نتفق على كل شيء احيانا نختلف رايي
وبالها شكله اختلفنا في مسالتي
في الختام نحن نؤمن بنا مواقفنا كان اول
موقف الصحيح هو اعبر عن ذلك مع استقرار
اسعار النفط العنوان
تجاه السوق النفط الاوسع واقتصادات العالم
والنضمنه توفير هذا الاستقرار ولكن
ستقندنا حوار قوي مع شركائنا في امريكا
والاحلي هذه المسائل ولكن بشكل عام هذه
العلاقات حققت فوائد الجمل ليس فقط لبلدين
بل لمنطقتنا وبينما نستمر بمعالجه المساله
التي حدثت عنها
وسنتر
فيجب ان نعمل معا كلنا يجب ان نعمل معا
وهذا يعني
المستعان الخليجي والمملكه المتحده
والولايات المتحده الكل يجب ان يعمل معا
لمعالجه هذه التحديات
ming
فلن نتمكن من معالجه التحديات الكبرى
تواجه العالم
وهتشارككم وجهه نظر هذه نعم بشكل كبير من
الاشياء التي
الجماعات الديمقراطيه والجمهوريه في مجلس
الشيوخوان
الجمله الامريكي بشكل عام واغلبه حلفاء
وشركانا في العالم هو موقفنا التجاهل
اعتداء روسيا الدموي ضد اوكرانيا في البدء
كانت هناك بعض المخافه تعبر عنها العديد
من الناس
ومع مرور الوقت اتفق مع صاحب السمو مع
الاستقرار الى اسرار ومع حوض المسجد
الحوارات ادركنا بانه هنالك مسار ايجابي
همم في هذه العلاقه ولكن الكثير من ابقى
اتجاهها المسار المستقبل لاوكرانيا وضمن
التزام واستقرار واستثمارات
توفر لقاده اوكرانيا وهؤلاء الذين يقاتلون
على ارض المعركه توفر لهم الثقه
وتشجيعهم
مع علمها من هذاك الكثير نحو العالم يقفنا
جانبهم
سنعود الى مساله اوكرانيا
المملكه الى دوله قطر الشيخ محمد همم
العلاقه العربيه السعوديه
المنطقه فيها التعقيدات قطر
سعيده جدا
همم
اين ترى دوره الغاز الطبيعي ليكون جسرا
بين
اسيوبيسو ساعده
تعتمد
والتي تعتمد على طاقه متجدده ودوره قطر في
هذه المساله والسؤال الثاني نحن نتحدث عن
الكثير من نزاعات في العالم وقطر ايضا
اللاعب الدوران تحت قيادتكم
الدور النهاما في التسويه والسلام ولكن
نرى في الكثير من النزاعات الامر صعب
الى الماء ولكن من المستحيل ربما ان نرمها
على شرب الماء او التعرف على رايكم فيما
اخلص اخر تطورات فيها افغانستان والتي
كانت مصدقه كبير لنا جميعا
دعوتي وانا سعيد جدا
لاجل السائل الاجانب هذه النخبه المتحدثين
فيما يخص الجزء الاول من سؤاليكا حول
الطاقه والدوره الغاز الطبيعي المثال نحن
في قطر
نؤمن بان الغاز امنه وانظف واكثر اعتمادا
كما اصدر طاقه ونؤذن بان الغاز سيبقى مهما
والوقود
المطلوبه ولكنه مزيج وطاقه مهمه جدا
للعقود القادمه عندما نتحدث عن جدته
التحول
سوء الحظ ان الكثير من صنع القرار
ااه حددوا اهداف لا يمكن تحقيقها واهداف
طموحه جدا
ولم يدركوا بان هذا سكن بحاجه الى الوقت
او استثمارات كبيره
وشاهد اقرا الطاقه
اوكرانيا
لهذه السياسات
همم ذس اندرتيكر بان قله الاستثمارات هذه
والتي لم تتبعها قطر لحسن الحظ سمحت لنا
الان بنت تكون ايدينا هذه القدرات
الاضافيه
التي يستبدا في عام 20 27 من اجل توفير
المزيد من الغازي الى السوق وخاصه الى
اوروبا
بما انهم بداوا بتنويع مصادرهم
اعتبار هو مهم جدا المحافظه على الغاز
والتنويع المصادر
وكذلك
الاستمرار بالتركيز المصادر الطاقه الاخرى
الى ان تصل هذه الاهداف
طيب همم
انذر البروستبكتي
الانصاف الكثير من الدول الناميه
طالب منها بعدم تنميه مصادرهم او مواردهم
وبينما لا يزالون في حاجه
اليها في رحلتي التنميه والكثيره من الدول
في العالم ترى الدول اكثر تراا غير منصفه
تجاههم من خلال مطالبتين بوقفي
التنميه
مصادرهم الخاصه النقطه الثالثه في هذا
الخصوص لست متاكدا ان كان هناك نقاش او
حوار صادقا حول اجنده التحول واي نوع من
الضرر
قد تتسبب به الارض عندما نتحدث عن
التعدين او البحث حتى عن المعادن من اجل
استخدامها
كمدخله لكل هذه الطاقه المتجدده ومعدتها
نحن
نؤمن
اعمق واكثر شموليه وبمشاركه كافه الدول
وليس فقط مجموعه السبعه او الدول المتقدمه
لتحديد اجنده العالم
همم
او
الرولدعات وكما ذكرت وبحقه هذه المهمه
ليست سهله
الاتفاق
ولكن من اصعب المحافظه واستدامه الاتفاق
ونحن ندرك حقيقه انه ليس من السهل لدوله
مثل افغانستان والتي عانت ليس فقط خلال 20
عاما الماضي من الحروب حتى ابعد من ذلك
وربما خلال اربعين عمل الماضيه وهم
يتقاتلون فيما بينهم لا نستطيع ان اتوقع
من اتفاق حصل بينهم والولايات المتحده
سيحقق السلام في بلادهم خلال يوم او حتى
عام
انه خاصه وانه لم يكن هنالك وحوار حقيقي
بين اطراف الحرب انفسهم اقصد الافغان او
الحوار الداخلي لم يحصل بشكل ملان ما حصل
مؤخرا
والاجراءات الاخيره من قبل حكومه طالبان
في افغانستان كانت مخيبه لامالنا
وقد حذرناهم الاتحاد مثل هذه القرارات
التي
ستجعل اوضاعه اسوا للشعب الافغاني وكذلك
للمجتمع الدولي وان يتعامل معهم هل هذا
يعني باننا سنتوقف او سنوقف جهودنا كان لا
سوف نستمر
همم دوائر
ومن بعض الاشخاص ربما يكون من الصعب يتحدث
اليهم ولكن هذا السبيل الوحيد المضيق دوما
من اجل ايجاد الحلول ولا فما البديل
البديل سيكون هو حربا اهليه واضطرابات
داخل افغانستان والتي ستنفجر على المنطقه
باكملها
فيما يخصوا المثل الاخيره عندما يكون
هنالك حوار بين الاطراف هذا الشيء ولكن
اصحاب القرار ايضا في عندها هارون هل
تعتقدون ان هناك امل في المستقبل القريب
لحصولي حوار على ذلك وتغيير القرارات امن
نحن نتحدث عن
المجال المتوسطه والبعيد
منذ البدايه ونحن نبذل كل مابي ويسعين من
اجل تواصل معهم اما بشكل مباشر من قبلنا
او حتى عبر دول اخرى في المنطقه وخاصه
الدول المسلمه حيث نرى انها تلعب دورا
كبيرا في مثل هذه المسائل خاصه الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه اليفغانستان
حاولنا حتى ان نتواصل
حوار معهم الى الان لم نجح
ولكنه
بتشاورتها مستمره مع دوله اخرى في المنطقه
وبعض الدول المسلمه من اجل
اذ اذن التواصل
والتحدث معهم حول هذه المساله
والاجراءات والتي كانت للاسف
اتخذت من دين من دون اي عقلانيه
حتى من
شرحها بشكل منطقي لان
فاعتقد بين الوظيفه لن تكون سهله ولكن من
المهم جدا الاستمرار بالمحاوله
والاصرار على دفع هذا التغيير
والى ان ارى تغيير الحقيقيه على الارض
شكرا جزيلا
تحدث عن جيل كامل من الفتيات والنسائي
وحقهن في التعليم
والنعمه لن يكون هنالك سبيل لتجاوز هذه
العقبه القدس
سنعود الى اوروبا
منذ سنوات طويله
الرئاسي
او اكثر تحديدا لبلادكم خلال عقود
هل همم
انت الشخص الذي سوف يضم في الانديه الى
الناتو
في الحقيقه
كان هكذا لحولها انها قبل بدا في ال 24 من
فبراير في العام الماضي وانتهى في مايو
عندما قدمنا وثائقينا الى النار
السويد
هناك اكبر
حزبي
اتفق على ذلك تماما وحتى التحالف الجناح
على اي ساره مع برنامج
للسياساتها غير روسياساتهم وصوتوا لصالحنا
موحده جدا في هذا الخصوص لكن فيما خصوصا
ست اوكرانيا يجب ان اقول بان النجعات
السوداء تاتي الان من اوروبا والمخاطره
تاتي من اوروبا لانه نفكر فيها انواع
مختلفه من التسعيدي في النساء
بحاجه الى طرفين من اجل تحقيقه
وبعد ذلك اعتقد بان
او عندما نتحدث عن التعدديه
تعمل في مثل هذا الوقت هل سكيكات المكان
التي اصدرك فيها 95 وكان نهايه للحرب
البارده والان فنلندا ستتراسو
بعد 55 عاما من الاحتفالات
الحقيقيه لان هيك هي محطمه
ولكنه يدافع عن الاتحاد
مساء كبيره لانه متحده لا تستطيع ان تدافع
عن اوكرانيا
كتبنا وثقه وفقا لميثاق المتحده الماده 51
فدول اذا ما هو هجمتهم كان يطلب المساعده
من الدول الاخرى الى ان تحل المشاكل في
مجلس الامن ونحن وصلنا هذه المرحله
قد المساعده وبنتظار مجلس الاملاح لهذه
المشكله ولكنه المشكله المعركه الحقيقيه
في مجلس الامن في مجلس الامن لدينا
الجمعيه العامه التي اتخذت موقفنا اخلاقيا
عاليا في هذه المساله ومهمه همم ان يكون
هناك اتفاق دوله حول هذه المساله ولكن في
نفس الوقت يجب ان عملا عبر المنظمات
العموميه عن الغذاء
والطريق الاخر يحقق خاصه النجاح لاصال
لحبوب قبل يومنا كشف مع سيد جرسين من
الوكاله الاداريه كانت في اوكرانيا لتامين
يعتقنه نوويه وحتى
تبادل الاسرى واعتقد ان الاتراك بنجاح في
انقره حول هذه المساله وهذا يظهر بان هذه
القنوات مفتوحه
وقنوات الحوار مفتوحه ولكن من مهم جدا
ان نبقى متضامنين مع اوكرانيا لدفاع
الاستقلالهم وحدودهم وانا مواطنه فخور من
الاتحاد الاوروبي لاننا في البدايه الكل
كان المشاركه كانك كيف ستردها يرد الاتحاد
نحن
نقدم الدعم المستمر
وبريطانيا ولكن التحدي الاكبر يبقى كيف
نخرج روسيا من اوكرانيا وكيف نحقق السلامه
دائم في المنطقه واي نوع من ضمانات يمكن
ان يوفرها لي اوكرانيا
طنطا فيها 1300 كيلو متر من الحدود مع
روسيا